how's it going everybody it's Warren and
welcome back to the channel today we
have some really exciting news about a
couple of different things but all
relating to spider-man spider-man has
possibly been the biggest most
talked-about Marvel topic since the
sonne spider-man deal with Disney and
Marvel kind of went south but then of
course they struck a new deal for
spider-man
to remain in the MCU but during this
time where nobody really knew what was
going to happen whether spider-man was
going to go back just to Sony or if he
was going to remain in the MCU fans made
it very clear that they do want
spider-man's character in the MC with
the rest of the characters and now it
seems like according to some reports and
according to some websites that are
close to Marvel Studios and are starting
to speculate that we could probably get
more than one spider-man in the MCU with
a multiverse that's right I'm talking
about a live-action spider-man into the
spider-verse with multiple versions of
Peter Parker versions that could include
Tobey Maguire spider-man from the Sam
Raimi series and Andrew Garfield
spider-man as well and to top it all off
we actually have reports that say Marvel
Studios is eyeing to do a spider-gwen
movie as well a live-action spider-gwen
movie now everybody has loved
spider-gwen for a very long time she's a
really popular and lovable character so
this report that says that Marvel would
like to do a spider-gwen movie comes out
little to no surprise it actually makes
perfect sense but a spider-man
multiverse where we could see Tom
Hollands spider-man Tobey Maguire
spider-man and Andrew Garfield
spider-man all in the same room in the
same time is something that we didn't
really know we wanted until we saw
spider-man into the spider verse where
multiple versions of spider-man all come
together but now of course everybody is
dying to see Tom Holland Tobey Maguire
and Andrew Garfield as their own
spider-man characters in one film and it
looks like it could happen I'll break
down these reports thoroughly about a
live-action spider-man into the
spider-verse with Tobey Maguire and
Andrew Garfield and of course Tom
Holland and then of course the
possibility of a spider-gwen movie if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
can stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU I'm also giving away
an Xbox one and a ps4 and all you have
to do is subscribe and notifications
turned on like the video and leave a
comment below to enter spider-man into
the spider-verse was a very popular and
a very successful movie it earned over
three hundred and seventy five million
dollars at the box
and the budget was only 90 million but
the most important thing about the movie
is that the fans loved it and of course
after it came out and then we had
Spiderman fire from home coming out
where we saw a trailer where Mysterio
mentioned the multiverse many people
thought that in Spider Man far from home
we could see some type of live-action
version of spider-man into the
spider-verse
with multiple versions of Spider Man
coming in the main universe from
different universes however of course
this turned out to be a lie Mysterio was
lying about the multiverse he was
actually from the same universe and that
was kind of a bummer but now we do have
an actual multiverse and we're starting
to connect the dots on how a live-action
spider-verse could be set up right now
according to Mikey Sutton who has been
known to leak accurate information about
spider-man
he says that the relationship between
Sony and Marvel is now stronger than
ever and in fact they've worked out a
new deal this deal involved the use and
a reference of spider-man characters in
the Sony verse and according to Mikey a
live-action spider-verse movie has
Marvel Studios deeply interested one
that could have Tom Holland meeting his
predecessors and of course we all know
who his predecessors are Andrew Garfield
and Tobey Maguire so just imagine a
movie where you see Tom Holland
spider-man fighting alongside Tobey
Maguire spider-man and Andrew Garfield
spider-man that's what could happen in
the future however there are some people
that suggest that Marvel is already
setting this up
according to comicbook.com it's possible
that Marvel Studios has already begun
setting up a live-action spider-verse
and they've done it recently in Morbius
now there are two possible things that
could be happening in Morbius width um
showing spider-man on the wall one is
that there simply is no connection to
the MCU whatsoever Sony is simply using
their rights to Sam Raimi spider-man by
putting him on the wall and trying to
build hype and then of course vulture
may not be the vulture from the MCU
instead it could just be some character
that Michael Keaton is plain however
Mikey Sutton says that his sources say
this is not true there actually is
something in development here and that
actually is vulture from the MCU so
according to comic book calm this is how
Marvel Studios and Sony could be setting
up a live-action spider-verse with
Morbius the picture on the wall and the
Morbius trailer says murderer this is
obviously picking off of the spider-man
far from home post
scene where Mysterio says that Peter
Parker killed him
however the spider-man suit that is in
the picture is Tobey Maguire spider-man
and he also appeared in spider-man ps4
so clearly they are connecting
spider-man to the events and spider-man
5 from home which take place in the MCU
but why didn't they use Tom Hollands
spider-man costume well this is what
comicbook.com says could be happening
this is an alternate universe tied to
the MCU but independent of the events of
the MCU meaning a true Marvel Cinematic
Universe exists so the universe that
Morbius exists in the spider-man in that
universe is actually Tobey Maguire
spider-man and this is a world that Tom
Hollands spider-man could travel to
creating a true spider-verse
now this actually makes a lot of sense
if we look at some of the facts here one
is that it doesn't really make any sense
that they put Sam Raimi's version of
spider-man in the picture but they also
put murderer over it the fact that it
says murderer clearly means that it's
coming from the post-credits scene from
spider-man far from home so why put the
Sam Raimi suit well because the
spider-man in that universe that was
accused of being a murderer is actually
Tobey Maguire spider-man and that's why
he has the suit because it's actually
him so basically in the morbius universe
Tobey Maguire is spider-man and of
course we know where the MCU is heading
they are setting up the multiverse so
since the multiverse is real in the MCU
it would make total and absolute sense
that Peter Parker Tom Hollands Peter
Parker could travel to a different
multiverse to escape the world and in
this universe where Tobey Maguire
spider-man exists anything that Peter
Parker does Tom Hollands Peter Parker
won't affect the MCU at all because it
exists in another universe but it does
affect Tom Hollands Peter Parker this is
a sort of way to kind of give everybody
what they want the fans want a
live-action spider-verse
and Sony and Marvel both want a
live-action spider-verse as well and
this way they get to do one that
technically does exist in the MCU
however it's set in an alternate reality
so it doesn't affect the main MCU
timeline this is and everybody wins
situation Marvel wins Sony wins and the
fans win and not to mention this would
make billions at the box office
Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield
returning to be with Tom Holland it'll
make a billion dollars for sure and then
they
could add in one more character a
live-action spider-gwen as I mentioned
in the beginning spider-man fans have
been in love with spider-gwen for a very
long time and of course she was in
spider-man into the spider verse and
played a very important character
well according to another report from
Mikey Sutton Disney has a mad crush on
Gwen Stacy she is a very big following
and according to Mikey such an Marvel
wants to put her up front and center in
her own film after spider-man 3 now of
course the Gwen Stacy has been in
previous spider-man films she's been in
spider-man 3 where she was played by
Bryce Dallas Howard and of course she
was in the amazing spider-man where she
was played by Emma Stone but according
to this report Marvel isn't just
planning on introducing Gwen Stacy they
want spider-gwen and they wanted to
fully take place inside of the MCU with
her teaming up with some of the young
Avengers which we know are coming so if
Marvel Studios and Sony of course is
planning on introducing a spider gwyn
into the MCU and have her interact with
some of the young Avengers and Marvel
Studios and Sony is planning on
introducing a live-action spider-verse
spider Gwen will most likely make an
appearance in the live-action
spider-verse as well just as she did
into the animated series spider-man into
the spider verse and this all lines up
extremely well to actually happen in the
not-too-distant future clearly Sony and
Marvel are planning something with
spider-man and a multiverse as we've
seen again Sam Raimi spider-man in the
Morbius trailer and this could very well
be the big team-up film that Marvel
Studios and Sony made a deal with for
spider-man to appear in the MCU with the
new Sony Disney deal we know that they
worked out a film for a single solo
spider-man film and then a crossover
film now it's been widely speculated
that this could be Captain Marvel 2
which does kind of make sense if you
consider the fact that Maria Hill and
Nick Fury were actually Talos and his
wife the whole entire time during
spider-man far from home however if you
have one movie in the New Deal that you
worked out you probably aren't going to
waste it on Captain Marvel - you'll
probably want it to be a much bigger
film well what if this film this
crossover event has something to do with
Doctor Strange sending Peter Parker into
a different universe after all Doctor
Strange - is called Doctor Strange in
the multiverse of madness perhaps some
of the multiverses are actually
colliding this could be how we see more
than one
version of spider-man in a single film
Tom Hollands spider-man goes into the
Morbius universe and there he encounters
Tobey Maguire spider-man and there
another universe collides where we see
Andrew Garfield spider-man and then
spider-gwen as well and all of the
alternate universes starting to collide
could be the start of battle world
Avengers secret Wars this is widely
believed and heavily speculated to be
the next Avengers in-game type of event
now of course this will take place way
down the road probably not until another
ten years but it has to be built up just
like Avengers endgame was built up and
one of the premises for one version of
the battle world event is that the
multiverses actually collide into each
other
well Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness and a live-action spider-verse
could all be the beginning of this and
again Marvel Studios and Sony knows that
everybody wants to see a film with Tom
Hollands spider-man Tobey Maguire
spider-man and Andrew Garfield
spider-man so they'd be absolutely crazy
not to try to make it happen but let me
know what you think about this would you
like to see a live-action spider-verse
with Andrew Garfield Tobey Maguire and
of course Tom Holland and then
spider-gwen as well let me know in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and of course subscribe but
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to the
MCU Xbox one and ps4 giveaways are in
the description down below don't forget
to follow me on Instagram and Twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching we'll fluff